yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah if you follow my games on leeches I
always have a couple of observers and
you might recognize that I did not
upload one game the game before I
couldn't upload that game it was
impossible I am my opponent blundered
two points in the opening pretty much
okay it's very tough to not call it like
a beginner and then I blended everything
back and I was cursing so hard it was
impossible for me to upload that I mean
it was just not suitable to show anybody
I'm really sorry about this I shouldn't
really lose temper like that but I was I
was just like I was just so frustrated
and yeah so it it just it cannot be
uploaded simply I really I really don't
mind so much blundering here and there I
mean I do and those games go go usually
I just upload them and it's it's it's
what it is but I was just I was just so
utterly frustrated and you cannot put it
put it on the channel possible okay so
and this guy has to has to suffer yeah
it's not really his fault but so let's
let's see if I can go for a quick
checkmate that's a that's a bit of a
tilting approach I have to admit that
but it looks dangerous right
it really is dangerous because he does
not have f6 available and that is a bit
of a problem
I wonder if well if he takes d4 there's
rook t1 so it's not a big problem I
think yeah here there's e5 is the thing
so
23 hat 95 so how do we how do we win
this now probably just this one
that it's impossible to defend I think
but how exactly do we win this night
deform and I guess still not not a maid
maybe night c5 is actually a threat
Knight c5 Knight to e6 something like
that here I can take on f6 and Queen f6
I think should not save the day
[Music]
still how exactly 94 for week f5 young
should win
and the bishop age six is also on the
resource so queenie six look at five
check okay just
we need the queen is enough
and we gauge one yesterday can I see
cannot get over the game before I really
disliked not uploading a game but I was
just like just I wish is blurting out
like you're like I know what I said
exactly I was I was actually not
insulting my opponent but myself but it
was just too bad it was too bad to to
upload okay so this game we had an an
end time anti green felt each for a
decent lines really well playable line
age five I think usually the idea is a
for now that I remember it and then
after this white is claiming that this
insertion of moves has helped him but we
cream III cannot be terrible he went C
6e form yeah I was still quite happy I
think that the insertion of the H pawn
moves is quite helpful Bishop g7
and now this is the city's dangerous
just what it is we should see form yeah
should see four looks very okay now g4
is the engine Wow
that's that wasn't super obvious really
yeah I mean it looked very dangerous I
honestly but it seems to be strong so
this takes h5o plus four okay so yeah
then that was it was a bit bit of a bit
of tilting but it wasn't bad white is
attacking with with everything and that
everything is a lot so here here I
wanted to go
did I wanted to play 95 I think I wanted
to play no it's too much
yeah here I won the Queen and with it
the game yeah this this this this whole
complex here is very I think quite
annoying for black because white has so
many options that are promising h4 is
one of them there's Queen b3 - Queen a
for Queen a4 on the move before it's
it's a bit it's a bit much I think to
deal with not that it is objectively
terrible it's it's really a lot even
civilian is just 24 video series he
avoided this entire oon felt because he
said White has too many options that
need attention ok guys thanks for
watching